Hey man.
>> Hey.
>> So I'm assuming you if I ask the same
question as before, you want to talk
about 1094. Is that correct?
>> Yes.
>> Okay. I just cur out of curiosity, did
you read the full chapter, chapter 10?
>> I have.
>> Okay. Um, what what story is it telling
before this verse comes up?
>> Right before this one, it mentions the
Exodus and Pharaoh.
>> Yeah.
>> Before that, it mentions Noah. Before
that, it mentions how the Quran is in
line with the previous scriptures and is
a confirmation of them. He mentions a
lot of different things.
>> Okay. Um, is the Exodus in in the Bible?
>> Yep.
>> Is the story of Noah in the Bible?
>> And so what's the confusion with 1094?
>> Well, in 1094, it says that if Muhammad
is doubting the things that was revealed
to him in the Quran, then he can go
check the previous scriptures to make
sure the Quran is right. So the pro the
the issue is is that well, it's not it's
not an issue. The issue is that you guys
deny this. But the verse is clearly
communicating that the previous
scriptures are the standard of truth
regarding these things. Would you agree?
>> If you take it out of context, I see I
can get confusing. But if you keep it in
the context of what this chapter is
about and what was revealed, which is
like the Exodus and the story of Noah.
Um, essentially it's saying if if you're
in doubt, and it's kind of a rhetorical
because of course Muhammad peace be upon
him was not in doubt and he didn't go
ask anybody. But it's kind of a
rhetorical thing for for him and as well
for the disbelievers. If if you're in
doubt about what we're revealing, what
we just revealed to you about the Exodus
and about Noah, go to the previous
scriptures and you'll see that these
stories are also there so you know
they're true.
>> Right. So [clears throat] the the
previous scriptures then are the
standard on the Quran getting this stuff
right. Correct.
>> By this stuff, if you mean
>> the stories
>> these these stories that are in this
chapter. Yes.
>> Okay. So if the Quran is not in line
with the previous scriptures regarding
these stories, then the Quran is false,
right?
>> I'd say that the other way around. If
the previous scriptures were chained,
the Quran came essentially as a
correction to the previous scriptures
because there were parts of it that were
corrupted and parts of it that are still
true. So essentially what it's saying is
that these stories were revealed before
you and here's the confirmation for what
actually happened. Like I'll give you an
example. Um
>> please please don't please don't. I
heard what you said. I I completely
understand what you said. There's
nothing in the Quran that says what you
said. Um, and there's so much wrong with
what you said in light of the verse
because it's like,
>> but the Quran itself does say that it
>> it's like you guys you guys bring in the
opposite of what Allah has just said.
Okay. How how is how is Muhammad if he
doubted? Not saying he did. If he
doubted, how is he supposed to check to
make sure the Quran is right? How does
he verify it according to the verse
>> for these stories to to verify with
those who have read the scripture
before? To verify with them. And so what
is their source? What is their source of
verification that's going to
>> the the Torah and the
>> Gotcha. So the scriptures go.
>> Yes.
>> So Muhammad has to go essentially and
check the scriptures to make sure the
Quran got these stories right. Correct.
>> In a in a way. So let me can I can I
just kind of rephrase it in a different
way?
>> Sure. So, if we like just imagine that
we're back 1,400 years ago and for the
first time we're hearing um this person
that claims to be a prophet and they
come up with these stories about this
flood that happened and this pharaoh
that chased Moses, peace be upon him. Um
some of the people at the time probably
are like these sound like some
fantastical stories. Is this guy just
making this stuff up? And then it comes
and Allah subhana wa ta'ala says if you
oh Muhammad or of course this this book
is for all people. Uh but if you're in
doubt about what we revealed then go ask
those who had been reading the
scriptures before you. So then you say
okay back 1400 years ago I go to to
Christians and to Jews and I ask them do
they know the story of this guy Moses?
Do they know the story of this guy Noah?
And they say yeah we know the stories.
And they tell you the stories and
they're in line and then I know okay
this Quran is indeed coming from
Allahhana wa tala. So, how did you
determine if the Quran was coming from
Allah or not?
>> I confirmed with the for those stories,
I confirmed it with the scriptures
before.
>> So, the scriptures before are the
standard regarding these stories on
whether or not the Quran is correct on
these things, right?
>> To a degree. Yes.
>> No, it's not to a degree. It's either it
is or it isn't. It's what everything
that you just said, bro. Everything you
just said leads to the conclusion that
the standard of truth regarding the
stories of Noah and the Exodus and
Pharaoh and the Israelites, right, is
the previous scripture. And if the Quran
is in line with those stories in the
previous scripture, then you know that
hey, this actually came from Allah. If
it's not in line with with them, then
you know that it didn't come from Allah.
Right.
>> Yeah. So in general the stories it what
it's it's referring to in general are
these stories are true but not every
single detail is correct in the day
gospels.
>> Say it doesn't say that. It says if you
are in doubt regarding that which we
have revealed to you. Now if you want to
hold it to the story specifically in the
chapter fine that means that everything
that the Quran just said regarding these
stories has to be in line with the with
the previous scriptures. It cannot
contradict what the previous scriptures
say. So now grant let's say it has an
extra detail that's not necessarily
contradictory may be fine but it cannot
go against the the the story in the
previous scripture or else you know that
it's not from Allah right
>> let me ask you this if it's 95% the same
but there's little details that are
corrected the overall story and the
message of the story is still the same
it's intact but Allahh corrects
differences
>> if something is being corrected is it in
line with what it's correcting
>> if it's a if it's a minor correct in the
overall message and the overall story is
the same then. Yes.
>> If if what I have is correcting what you
have is what I have in line with what
you have.
>> It should be almost completely in line.
>> Jesus Lord is is my Lord of hosts.
Listen to the question. My my dear
brother in humanity. If something is
correcting
another thing, are those two things
compatible? The correction and the
incorrection. Are they compatible?
You're thinking you have to think about
this
>> because it's because you're trying to
you're trying to phrase it as a question
where it's a yes or no and it's not
that.
>> It is a yes or no. It's a yes or no.
See, this is the gift that God has given
me. I am able to break down what can
seeming seemingly be complex issues to
very simple issues that can be a yes or
a no. It can be black or white. God has
given me that.
>> No, because verse 104.
>> It's really simple. No, don't take
nothing else. Don't say nothing else
unless you're answering the question
because I I let you dodge twice. Now I
have to hold you to nurse. I'll answer
your question.
>> Thank you.
>> I'll answer your question.
>> Is a correction in line is a is a
correction compatible with the
incorrection? Are those two things
compatible?
>> No.
>> Thank you. So if it's not compatible,
then they're not in line with each
other. Agreed.
>> Correct. So if it's correcting whatever
the thing is, whatever the subject is
correcting, whatever the object that's
being corrected, it's not in line with
the corrector. That's why it's a
correction. They're not compatible. So
you can't say, hey, there's things in
the story that they're they got some
things in line with it, but it's
correcting some things. That means that
the story that's in the Quran is not
compatible with the story that's in the
previous scriptures. If the Quran is
so-called correcting what's in the
previous scripture, they're not
compatible. Make sense?
>> Yes. Now, read read the verse that
you're mentioning again, 1094. What does
it say?
>> It says, "If you are in doubt about that
which we have revealed to you, meaning
if you are uncertain about the truth
about what we have revealed to you,"
this is what he tells him to do to find
out if it's true or not. go and ask
those who've been reading the scripture
before you. So in order for Muhammad or
anybody else that this is applied to, in
order for them to have certainty about
the truth in what the Quran is talking
about in this context, they have to go
check with the previous scriptures. If
the Quran is in line with the previous
scriptures, they will be certain of the
Quran's truthfulness. If the Quran is
not in line with the previous scriptures
regarding this stuff, then they'll be
certain that the Quran is false
regarding these things. Make sense?
>> Mhm.
>> So that means that the previous
scriptures are the standard of truth.
They are the authority over the Quran at
least regarding the stories of the
prophets and the things mentioned in 109
chapter 10.
>> Okay.
>> Thank you.
>> So So can I ask a question now?
>> Of course. So, did the pagans in in
Mecca at the time of the prophet peace
be upon him, did they ever hear the
stories of Moses in of Noah? Did they
hear these stories before
>> the pagans? I'm I'm not sure. Probably
those those those uh stories were
circulating among the Jews in Arabia.
So, I I'm I'm not sure, but I would I
can assume so. Yeah, I can make an
inference.
>> Okay. Do do you think all of them had
heard it?
>> Maybe not everybody.
>> Okay. So, if you're somebody who in that
time who had not heard of these stories
of Moses splitting the sea, who had not
heard the story of Noah uh building an
ark in a flood wiping out all of his
people, is it a logical deduction to
make that if you were a person in that
time, you would say, "Yeah, this sounds
a bit, you know, I'm okay with some of
this religious stuff. Give to the poor,
take care of the needy, but this is kind
of like too fairy tale fantastical for
me." Do you think some people would have
said that?
>> It's possible.
>> So, is it fair? Is it fair to deduce
that Allah subhana wa ta'ala revealed
this verse for them to let's say I live
in Mecca and I know there's some Jews in
Medina and I say I'm up with this this
religion this Muhammad peace be upon him
guy like I'm I'm following him up until
now but this seems like a fairy tale
that he's kind of made up in his mind I
don't believe you know splitting the sea
with your staff that sounds kind of
fantastical to me and I'm going to go
let me go okay this verse gets revealed
and it says go confirm with those who
had the scripture before like okay I
know some Jews in Medina let me go do a
trip to Medina and I'm going to go ask
the the Jews if if they've heard of this
Moses guy, if they've heard of this
splitting of the sea, if they've heard
of this Noah and this ark, if if this is
all like just did Muhammad peace be upon
him just make this up or is this
actually it says that it's in some
scriptures before? Let me go double
check cuz keep in mind 1400 years ago
not everyone was literate. Not not
everyone could read. Um most people in
Saudi Arabia were pagan. They didn't
follow any religion besides idol
worshiping. Um, so I think it's very
common, you know, amongst those people
and it's very possible that a lot of
these people thought that these were
like fairy tales that Muhammad peace be
upon him was making up. And so they went
to the pre previous people of scripture
and they asked him, "Hey, do you do you
know the story of Moses?" Well, tell me
the story of Moses. Oh, he well he ran
from Pharaoh and he um was put in a
basket and and you know raised by the
Pharaoh. He, you know, split the sea and
saved his people and all this stuff
happened. Oh, so Muhammad didn't make
this up. Actually, this is in the
previous scriptures. So, is that does
that kind of help explain the verse and
and why it was revealed that way?
>> In a way, sure. So, so you're but you're
confirming what I'm saying that Allah
points to the previous scriptures as a
standard of proof for what is for what
the Quran is saying.
>> Well, yeah, cuz Allahh revealed the
previous scriptures. So, so the stories
are there.
>> Exactly. So, that that's my point. My
point is is that from the Quran
standpoint, the previous scriptures are
a revelation from Allah. It makes
perfect sense that he would say, "Hey,
if you're doubting this new revelation
I'm giving you, go check my old ones.
They're perfectly in line with each
other, and you'll see that this new one
is from God. It's from me. It's a
revelation." That's that's my point. So
Allah uses the previous scriptures as a
standard for of evidence for the new
revelation. It's not. But the problem is
is that a lot of the Muslims, you guys
got it twisted the other way around. You
guys say that the Quran is the standard
of evidence that the Quran is the
standard of truth regarding uh the
previous scriptures. But that's it's the
other way around.
>> The only reason we say that is because
like we said, a lot of the Bible was
changed. Verses were added later that
are not found in the oldest Greek
manuscripts. There's stuff that was
emitted. There's 40,000 textual
variations. Nothing
nothing is missing. But here's the
point. All of these,
>> you know, in the very What's the oldest
full Bible available? How
>> that that matters not. That don't mean
nothing. We got We got manuscripts of
the Old Testament that go hundreds of
years before Jesus. We got manuscripts
of the New Testament that date to the
second century, 3rd, fourth, fifth, 6th,
7th, and beyond. So the point is is that
what we have is what the Jews and
Christians had even in Muhammad's time
and before. You know what I'm saying?
>> That's what true. So I find it I find it
hard to believe that the the oldest so
I'll help you if you you can Google
this. You don't have to take my word for
it. The oldest full Bible that exists
New Testament came 300 years after Jesus
peace.
>> No that does that's not what came from.
That's the dating of it. But is that is
that before Muhammad?
>> 300 years roughly before Muhammad came.
Yes.
>> So is that the they would have had that
during Muhammad's time?
>> Yeah. So Muhammad is confirming the
Torah and Gospel that's in his time and
the Christians had Codex and Attakus in
his time. That's what you're referring
to.
>> Yeah.
>> So Codex Anatus is the word of God
>> partially. It's corrupted though because
it took 300 years to be fully written
down. A lot can change at all. Five
generations. You're missing it. Codex
Anaticus is a manuscript of a full full
all the books are there. Instead of the
manuscripts being spread, this is a this
is a um what do you call it? Compiled.
The books are compiled. That's the
oldest compilation of the Bible that we
have. That doesn't mean that these
scripts these manuscripts didn't exist
before which we have. We have we have
manuscripts.
>> You have you have some manuscripts. Yes.
Compilation.
>> Okay. So when you talk about when you
talk about manuscript evidence, we have
what existed prior to Muhammad and
Muhammad was confirming the manuscripts
in the the gospel, the Torah that was
there in the seventh century. We have
what was there in the seventh century
and beyond that. So
>> sorry, let me correct one thing. He he
was correcting what parts of those
manuscripts were authentic because some
of them were not authentic.
>> He didn't correct how do you know what's
authentic and what's not?
>> You use the Quran.
>> Okay. Does the Quran say you use the
Quran or does the Quran say you use the
previous scripture?
>> The Quran says we sent this book u as a
>> confirmation. I'll paraphrase as a as a
No, that's this verse. There's other
verses in the Quran that say woe to
those who write the scripture of their
own hands and sell it for a cheap price.
>> No, no. This is what you need to do for
me. Okay. First, can we agree that
according to 1094, the previous
scripture in Muhammad's time is the
standard of truth
>> for those stories? I would say yes.
Awesome. So, this would mean that in
Muhammad's time, these stories were
preserved.
>> Sorry, I didn't read the full Bible. Can
can you just confirm that like in the
Bible it says it says indeed Moses split
the sea, Pharaoh was an oppressive
person, and like all those things are
the same?
>> It's not the same. Those things are in
there, but it's not the same as the
Quran tells it. The Quran contradicts
the story of the Exodus in a lot of
ways. Matter of fact, for one of them,
the Quran has Pharaoh uh uh basically
repenting and acknowledging Allah as
God, as the true God, the God of Moses
>> in his last few moments of life when
he's when he's drowning, then he then he
believes
>> and that doesn't that doesn't happen in
the Torah. That's not
>> so like there's stuff like that and
that's major stuff like that completely
contradictory to the to the story um in
the Torah. There's a lot of these type
of things. Okay. Now the point is though
is that this verse points to the
previous scriptures regarding these
things as the standard of truth. If the
Quran's not in line with them, then the
Quran is false.
>> But but does it say that every single
detail has to be confirmed or does it
say the story?
>> It's what we have sent down what we have
revealed to you. So that means
everything that Allah has said,
everything Allah has said has to match
up with what the previous scriptures
say. Not some of it, not part of it.
Everything Allah has said has to line up
with the previous scripture. If you're
in doubt about that which we have
revealed to you. All of those details
are being revealed by Allah. Then go and
ask those who've been reading the
scripture before you. So everything that
I said, you're going to be able to find
it in the previous scripture. So don't
doubt. If you're not able to find
>> I think that's a bit of an I think
that's a bit of an inference though. I
have to I have to admit that seems like
a bit of an inference because it says to
me I feel like that's a bit nitpicky
because you're you're taking if the
overall story is 98% right but one story
says that at the very end Pharaoh
repented and the other one doesn't you
know the overall story is the same the
message is the same
>> it's not
>> except Allahhana maybe adds on to that
story one thing that was not added or
that was not included in the previous
scripture
>> but it's not though see that's the point
it's not in line with it it's not the
same that's the problem it's supposed to
match.
>> He's not in the Bible's life. And
>> he dies. He just straight up dies as a
disbeliever. He dies to the
>> How does he die?
>> Uh he he gets drowned
>> until until his dying breath. He's
rejecting the God of uh Abraham, Isaac,
and Jacob.
>> And that's what the Bible says that he
rejected until his very last breath.
>> That it shows him dying in in rebellion
against God.
>> Okay. So as a as a Muslim then what I
would say is that as because we believe
the Quran is the single source of truth.
We would say that that last part was
corrupted and the Quran came to corrupt
that.
>> I know what you would say cuz you're a
Muslim. I know what you would believe
because you're a Muslim. But my point is
Revelation is that what you believe as a
Muslim is diametrically opposed to what
the Quran says. The Quran says the
opposite of what you believe. That's the
point. The Quran doesn't say, "Hey, if
the previous scriptures disagree with
the Quran, then the previous scriptures
are are are incorrect." If you're in
doubt about what the previous scriptures
said, if you're if you're in doubt about
anything that the previous scriptures
say, then go and ask go and check the
Quran that came after it. No, it says
the opposite. It says if you're in doubt
about what we revealed in the Quran,
then go and ask those who've been
reading the scripture before the Quran.
It's the opposite of what you believe.
You get what I'm saying? I'm challenging
you to go with what the Quran says. Warp
your belief to what the Quran says. Stop
going the opposite way.
>> Okay? So, so let me ask you this. If we
go back to my example, like let's say
you were you were back 1400 years ago.
You're a pagan, you know, idol
worshipper in Mecca. and you hear this
full story and at the end the story
changes and the Quran says one thing and
the Bible says another thing, right? Are
you going to be like, "Oh, there's one
there's one small detail that's
different." Or you going to say, "Oh,
cuz cuz my whole point was that
>> I'm going to say the Quran is false
because this dude is telling me cuz
really it's not even this guy talking to
me. It's supposed to be Allah's talking
to me through him."
>> So everything he is saying, he's
claiming it's not his own words. It's
God's words. And so God is telling me,
"Hey guys, if you're doubting what I'm
telling you, you can go check the
previous scriptures. It's going to be in
line." I take him up on that challenge.
I'm like, "Okay, let me go to the Jews
real quick. Let me go to the
Christians." Hey guys,
>> hold on. You say that with you say that
with today's knowledge of of all you
already know the story. Imagine Imagine
you're back and you've never heard the
story before.
>> I know. I'm saying I'm I'm with I'm in
your analogy. I'm someone who hasn't
heard. However, I'm talking to this
person who's claiming to be a a a medium
between God and man. God is speaking to
me through him. And so, God is telling
me that if I am doubting what he's
saying, then here's what I can do to
make sure to test whether this is
actually coming from God or not. Go
check with the pe the people who have
the scripture before him. Okay, cool.
I'm a pagan. I don't got no dog in this
fight, but he's telling me that I should
believe that he's a prophet. Here's a
way to test him. Okay, I'm gonna take
him up on that. Let me go then and check
with the Jews and Christians about these
stories. Hey, uh what does it what does
your scripture say about Pharaoh and and
the Exodus? Uh did did did he actually
end up um you know, believing at the end
of his life? Uh no. He he was cursing
God and died uh cursing God and
rebelling against God to his dying
breath. Oh, wow. Dang. Okay. That's
That's crazy. Um All right. Well, what
what about this? This says that, you
know, what about the story of Noah in
the flood? Did Did um um some of Noah's
did all of Noah's did one of his sons
drowned in the flood? Uh no. Actually,
all of Noah's sons survived. They all
made it on the ark. Not one of them
drowned in the flood with the
disbelievers. Oh, wow. Okay. So I took
Allah up on his challenge and I see that
what he is saying actually is not in
line with where he told me to go where I
can you know uh verify
>> that detail would be enough for you to
be like it's it's not the same.
>> One detail would it's enough to for me
to be like it's not the same when he
told me it is. He lied to me.
>> Okay. So, so if I So, if I told you if I
told you a story about a magical unicorn
that shot rainbows out of its head and
it flew at the speed of light and it
killed the most evil person on the
planet and the evil person on the planet
at the end didn't repent and that was
the end of the story. And you're like,
"Yeah, yeah, right. Magical unicorn
rainbow shooting out of its, you know,
horn." And I said, "No, it's true. Go
check with these people that existed
before me. They have revealed the same
story as well. If I if you know if you
went and they told you the exact same
story and they said at the end he
repented or whatever at the end he
didn't repent but I said at the end he
repented. Are you are you going to
believe that that story was true or are
you going to say that whole story is
false?
>> I'm still in doubt of this whole story
because I'm I'm going to say that what
you're receiving is not from God because
it got it wrong. That's what I'm going
to say. I'm not going to say that the
story is false. I'm going to find the
true story. I see where the what the
true story says. And I see that you
who's claiming to have gotten this from
God is wrong about what happened. That's
the point. The point is is that he's not
supposed to get any of this wrong. If he
does and and how we know, he tells us
how we know if we if he gets it wrong or
not by based on what the original said.
when I go and check the original like he
told me to do and see that he actually
has stuff that is not in the original
added stuff took away stuff mixed up
stuff I see oh what you got is not from
God obviously cuz God would have got
this right so let me tell you how how I
infer this verse and we can agree to
disagree cuz I don't I don't want to go
in like loops with you all day um cuz to
me I I put myself 1400 years ago and the
verse says if you're in doubt so
immediately I'm thinking somebody heard
a story and they think it's this fairy
tale kind of crazy story and they find a
hard time to believe it. The verse says
it's the same thing that was revealed to
those before you. And I say, "Okay, well
now I can go ask if this story is the
same." And then if I find out one small
detail at the end of the story changes,
I've already had enough from them
telling me that this story did exist in
their in their scriptures. The story
does exist that I'm no longer in doubt
of these verses. And now I can go to
another verse in the Quran that says
indeed we have come in the ver the Quran
has come to correct the corruption of
the injil and the Torah uh the gospels
in the the old testament the Torah um
and then once you have the full picture
of it you know that the Quran's supposed
to come and correct things you know that
this story that you heard at first you
were at doubt because it sounded like a
fairy tale you confirm that this story
actually is in the old scriptures now I
know okay this story is true and I know
that the Quran says it's going come and
correct these stories. And so now I can
take that last part that changed.
>> Stop.
>> That said that
>> I have to stop you right there. You just
you just added in something where the
Quran says it's it it's coming to
correct these stories. Where does it say
that? Where does it say that?
>> Let me get the exact verse. Give me a
second.
>> So you guys assume that the Quran is
supposed to be correcting the stuff when
the verse we're talking about says the
opposite. How do y'all do that? How?
This is a well, the Quran is supposed to
be a correction of these stories, a
correction of the previous scriptures.
If that's the case, why in the world is
Allah sending them to the scriptures to
check the correction of the Quran?
>> It's it's the it's sending you to the
scriptures for the overall story.
>> No, not for the overall story. To see if
the Quran is is correct, right?
>> No, it's to see if if because the whole
verse is if you're in doubt. So, if you
heard something and you doubt about
what? If you're in doubt about what?
>> If you're in doubt about the story
>> in where where
>> the story in the Quran.
>> Thank you. So if you're in doubt about
what the Quran is saying, right? How do
you check to see if the Quran is
correct?
>> It's not to see if the Quran is correct.
It doesn't say it doesn't the verse
doesn't say if you want to check if this
Quran is correct. It says if you're in
doubt about what we revealed.
>> What does it mean to doubt?
>> Which is a story.
>> What What does doubt mean?
>> Hold on. Hold on. It's it's a story that
was revealed. You have doubt about that
story. This This is important cuz now we
don't know what doubt means. What does
doubt mean, bro?
>> It's a lack of conviction that it's
true.
>> So, you don't know if it's correct or
not. Right.
>> Correct.
>> And so, all
>> it's not about being correct or
incorrect. It's about is this story even
a real thing that ever happened.
>> If you doubt, if you have a if you lack
conviction on whether or not something
is true, then you lack conviction on
whether or not this is a correct thing.
Right. I don't know why you're bringing
If I said I'm in doubt that God exists,
where does correct or incorrect have to
deal with that?
>> I need you to answer my question.
>> No, but but correct doesn't have to do
with doubt.
>> Really?
>> Okay, let me let me give you Let me play
devil's advocate.
>> No, don't doubt.
>> What does what does correct mean? This
is what this is what we have to do,
guys. This is what we have to do with
Muslims. Now, we got to break down what
correct means. We got to break down what
doubt means. We got to break down what
truth means. What does correct mean,
bro?
>> Correct means true.
>> What is a doubt? A doubt means you're
unsure
>> about what? If something is true.
>> A doubt can be about Yeah. If if
something is true or not, if something
exists or not.
>> So, by default, you're doubting or you
lack conviction. You're uncertain if
something is correct. Right.
>> But it's not always black and black and
white.
>> Is that correct?
>> Hold on. Hold on. I I doubt I doubt that
the universe is infinite.
>> So, you doubt if if it's correct to say
that the universe is infinite, right?
>> No, I just doubt that the universe is I
just have a doubt. I just don't believe.
I don't believe.
>> So you So you don't know. You are
uncertain about the fact the truth the
correctness of the world view that the
universe is infinite. Right.
>> Yeah. I don't believe it. I
>> So do you see how correct and truth are
you can interchange them? They're
interchangeable. If you doubt means that
you lack conviction. You are uncertain
about the truth of a thing. Truth.
Correct means truth. So if you doubt
then that means that you're uncertain
about the correctness of a thing.
Correct.
>> Sure. Do you see this is why these
things take so much longer than they
have to. So when it says if you are in
doubt concerning that which we have
revealed meaning the Quran if you're in
doubt about the Quran means you're
uncertain about the truth of the Quran
which means you're uncertain about the
correctness of the Quran regarding these
stories. Right.
>> Yeah. But your your your order there
falls apart because let me let me give
you a different order. If you are in
doubt about what we revealed to you and
what we revealed was a story. So if
you're in doubt, if you're unsure or you
disbelieve in these stories that we've
revealed, go check with the previous
scriptures and you'll see those stories
are there.
>> So good. So you're you're doubting if
the Quran got this stuff correct, right?
>> No, you're doubting that the whole story
even is a thing.
>> I appreciate you for coming, man.
>> Okay. Have a good one.
>> Take care. This is what we have to do
with Muslims. This is what we have to do
with Muslims. And he knows it, too.
Guys, uh, for the Muslims that's
listening, I want you guys to to hear
this because this this isn't me doing
this to you. You're doing it to
yourself. I want you guys to hear this.
I have a load of comments on YouTube. A
load of comments here on TikTok. The
audience is listening to you and they
are embarrassed. They're embarrassed for
you. Do you guys understand that? Like,
I'm not doing I'm not saying this to
talk mess. I'm reading the chat and the
the the on both sides. They are
embarrassed for you. You are humiliating
yourself when you show yourself to be
this dishonest. I don't have to say it.
They are sad for you. They're like,
"Man, are these guys serious?" They're
like, "Man, like, are Muslims Are
Muslims okay?" I'm telling you what the
chat's saying. This isn't me. The chat
is saying this. They're sad for you.
They're like, "Man, these guys are
impossible. These guys can't think.
These guys are dumb. Man, these guys are
humiliating themselves. This is
embarrassing. Remove him. Remove these
guy. This is what they're saying. When
you guys are this dishonest, bro, when
you Man, it's scary. It's It's really
scary what Islam does to to the human
being. It's scary. It's scary what Islam
It's. It's so demonic. Islam is a
demonic religion. And we're seeing it
guest after guest after guest after
guest after guest. We're seeing the
demonic fruit of Islam. embarrassing,
lying with no shame, dishonesty with no
shame, without a second thought. If you
guys are out there and you're
considering Islam, you're in this chat,
you just happen to find my my live
stream and you're considering Islam,
this is what you'll become. This is what
you're going to have to do to stay a
Muslim. Are you okay with that? Are
y'all okay with that? Are you okay with
having to turn your brain off, shut down
your morale, and walk and live as a
cancerfilled robot? Are you okay with
that? If you are, there's nothing I can
do for you except pray for you and pray
that God miraculously steps into your
life and saves you from the delusion,
the debauchery that is Islam. It's all I
can do for those of you guys who are
Muslims and you're watching this, you're
seeing this and you're like, "Dang." Cuz
I know you're there. I know you guys
have those thoughts. You guys tell me
all the time. Get out of Islam. You do
not have to stay in it. It's a false
religion. And you're seeing how clearly
false it is. You're seeing how you have
to lie to protect it. Lie to to game.
You seeing it. Come to Christ. You do
not have to do this. This burden where
you have to defend Allah and the Quran,
lying and being dishonest and playing
games. You don't have to do that with
Christ. You don't.